[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good morning good afternoon good evening
everyone welcome back to GameSpot we are
about half an hour away from EA and
vices reveal maybe not reveal they kind
of revealed it with an image earlier
this week was it yeah with that we can
pull that up in a little bit but we
we're gonna hear more about battlefield
5 battlefield V whatever you want to
call it today they understand how Roman
numerals work I'm like black ops 4
oh we are gonna be playing battlefield 1
for about half an hour I'm like mihari
here with Aaron Sampson I was going and
Rob Henry and we're gonna be playing
2016 battlefield one who I almost [ __ ]
that up sorry I almost messed it up
battlefield one from for about half hour
before we move on over to the stream for
battlefield 5 Rob's playing here didn't
play on a PC but uh Aaron you did get
the chance to hear a lot about
battlefield 5 you can't talk about it
until the reveal but uh we have a lot of
pretty pretty good insider info and
facial expressions don't break in bar
goes yeah we have a lot to talk about
yeah when they're done and that's gonna
be at 2 p.m. is when that embargo is
lifted so again they are starting the
stream at 1:00 they'll go hopefully for
an hour even even if they'd go less than
that we'll dip out of there and talk
about what they talk or you know covered
in that stream and then stick around
till 2 p.m. and we'll have all
everything we know so far about
battlefield 5 what am I gonna do just
like rip tape off your mouth
alright I'm gonna open up this stack of
notes that literally is you have like
seven pages of notes I'm gonna be
reading through half of it cuz yeah it's
a lot so oh yeah like we did with like
Red Dead Redemption - and stuff we're
gonna be playing the previous game for a
little bit just to kind of warm up and
get back into mood see this is what I'm
talking about man
I feel like this operations so you're
the only one playing I think we'll just
have to do some quick play you're gonna
fight a world or one by yourself Rob but
the one and
or 104 yeah I haven't played since they
brought the the Russian campaign into
the game what was the name of the actual
DLC and the name of the Czar I remember
we played at e3 and I did a stage show
interview but I unfortunately never got
to go back and play it yeah play I only
played like 15 hours of battlefield one
a couple of years ago yeah it's
interesting I really I was reviewing
titanfall 2 and also playing it at the
time for me a year I think a lot of
people have been experienced at that
field one and it's something we have to
see if they change in battlefield to you
but battlefield one was just felt like
this like a finely honed version of
battlefield where they did a lot of
things right and they went back to the
basics and went there just wasn't a lot
of depth like there was a lot of weapons
a lot of the weapons they were like 3 in
the menu but it was really one weapon
yeah would in previous battle games that
would have just been attachments and
like variants on that gun right I don't
know like why did you why you think you
fell off it's so quick but honestly it's
probably titanfall - I absolutely love
that game and I think titanfall came out
a week after battlefield was that the
case and I member I was squished right
between Call of Duty and I think that
like titanfall 2 and then battlefield
and then Call of Duty I might be getting
that answer I know Call of Duty was the
last one in November infinite warfare
but I just remember it all I know and I
think titanfall 2 is again one of my
favorite games that year Robb is like
your favorite and I know you liked it I
mean that was my house my game of the
year but like I had I was psyched for
benefit one before it came out like
everything about it I love it I remember
I went down to Redwood Shores to see a
lot of behind the scenes stuff kinda
like you did yesterday I jump out
myself and someone our UK office got to
check out a lot of it behind closed
doors and so much and it seemed great
after what hardline being the last
mainline game it's interesting hardline
had a very distinct personality and
style
there was a lot of people who didn't
really appreciate modes where you just
sort of drove in circles all day long
yeah there was a lot of stuff actually
that hardline did that people don't get
their credit for they like push forward
the sound engine a lot hit customization
they had melee weapons and we're all
different
like I heart light actually did move the
field forward then it was just kind of a
weird it came in at a weird time to like
people were very into like worried about
voice brutality and it was like a police
brutality game that was a very weirdly
prescient game and then they weren't
really sure if they wanted a cops and
robbers battlefield game as opposed to
just I don't know Special Forces or
something like that I don't know if John
Luke has that teaser image of
battlefield 5 queued up but at some
point whatever you want I'm look if you
do have it you probably throw up on the
feed and we can look at it because I do
want to talk about that a little bit
what what people are inferring from it
because I know there has been a lot of
there's been a lot of like speculation
based on what was it like EA or dice
tweeted it and then said like coming
Wednesday we'll have a 2 p.m. Pacific
stream I mean it's got it it's a guy in
goggles and like some spot like body
armor kind of right it reminds me of the
Italian campaign from battlefield 1 like
it's like it's a weird like historical
style they've developed so so thought of
rumors up until this point what people
think it might be like is it and
honestly it could be a sequel to this it
almost looks about like world war 1 ish
I mean it's it's either world war 1
again or it's world war 2 money those
goggles are they look old enough right
for like either-or and I think people
are people have been assuming for a
while world war two because call duty
went back to World War two despite the
fact they're going back to the future
with black ops four they went back to
World War two with Call of Duty World
War two so yeah yeah there he goes a
little clipped but you like he's wearing
goggles
if they keep in the in that trend of
that time period they've done like
they've done like two or three versions
of World War two already so they did
1942 which is funny my back and play
that the other day on origin and it
looks like an iPhone game though it is
shocking how like rudimentary that game
looks you're playing on what PC or
didn't yeah
the origin then they had 1943 which was
their arcade version the battlefield
which is actually a lot of fun it was
like just very light and there's a lot
of achievements and like just a couple
of guns in the game like I don't know
like eight guns or something like that
yeah and then Bad Company 2 had some
throwbacks to World War 2 in their
campaign the beginning of Bad Company 2
so they they've been there before and if
that's what they're doing now it'll be
interesting to see what they've what
they've learned sure from past games so
I know it's gonna be tough for you
because again you've seen stuff that we
can't talk about yet but trying to
disregard all of that obviously and
based on your time I know you played a
lot of battlefield 1 and obviously
you're probably our preeminent expert on
the series in general at GameSpot what
do you like it I know I'll ask you on a
more minut scale but on a broad scale
what are some big strokes you think
battlefield 5 needs to hit for you to be
like hell yeah I'm super onboard I'll
ask you Rob but you're busy Rob's in
Rob's an ace pilot yeah one of my
biggest issues with battlefield 1 was a
lack of focus on objectives and this has
been something that had a problem with
I'm gonna say it like ever since the
close quarters DLC for like battlefield
3 yeah yeah I mean Metro ended up being
a beloved map but there was a point
where they were just I feel like the
guys straight away from objectives
they're like everybody just likes
walking around and shooting each other
like forget the tanks just whatever
everybody can have everything like
classes or don't meet as much and in
that what they really went in the
direction I don't know like team
deathmatch just too much of a team
deathmatch in old battlefield in
conquest mode
you might have 10 kills in a game or you
might run across you might not run
across somebody for a little while and
then sit and defend the conquest points
so I won't focus on objectives again and
I've said this since battlefield 3 like
dimmer maps in battlefield 3 and in
Bethel one where they were conquest
Flags just in a ditch yeah what am i
doing in this ditch why am i dying
there's no actual strategic reason for
that yeah but I yeah I remember
I felt like over time starting with
three like you said fer me or at least
maybe would be LC for three they started
losing sight of what battlefield was or
if they knew what battlefield was but
they were still trying to adapt to a
market where call duty was king like
this quick like fast pace death matches
were what everybody wanted but then
basket 1 showed good signs of promise I
think I mean there are still elements of
that but I think it was a good way to
you know like they called it battlefield
1 because they were presumably going
back to their roots but what I
personally wanted from battlefield 5 is
I want them to really embrace what
battlefield is and I want to have those
you know especially now amidst this
whole battle royale craze I want them to
really go back to what makes battlefield
unique in the shooter space and like
you'd like you said you could maybe like
you could fire your gun your weapon like
12 times in a match but you'd still be
like maybe you'd be supplying your
allies with ammo maybe you'd be
providing cover support not killing
anybody necessarily but keeping people
pinned down maybe you'd be like holding
a strategic point that's gonna let
people come up but I felt like even
maybe even battlefield one little bit I
feel like I was doing that I felt like
it was a shooter on a big map and I know
I know that's not solely Farex I know it
did
do some really cool things and I think
it's fantastic game these craters for
one having craters formed naturally by
bombs than that yeah that weren't there
at the start of the match is actually
was a really cool development in
battlefield one the terraforming over
time was it was great yeah but also
detrimental right like I know like the
san quintin map right you could level it
like the entire city for the most part
and there's problem the problem would be
then that like flags
don't have any cover ready to sit there
just groan and you're just having a
difficult time try not to be seen in
battlefield 3 with LEvolution has the
same problem actually I never really
fixed it which was that half the time
the maps were really exciting before
they got a level looted yeah like the
Shanghai Tower was fantastic and there
was a point where people are having
servers that were just like do not drop
the tower because what's left is boring
yeah it's a rubble pile the towers cool
rubbles boring
so like the challenge of dice figuring
out what to do with our maps at all
stages is something that they've had to
tackle some three in doubt the points
also been an issue although the
behemoths leaving their skeletons behind
is oh yeah that he did that was pretty
cool I actually like had an impact right
like on the whole map there's people in
the chat and the server talking about
Falco 5 revealing they just said I'd
never thought to do this excited for a
multiplayer sequel two years after ok
but even watching this now I'm like man
I really wish I and you could still play
it like I wonder how many people play it
like a decent number still play about
them yeah I think so
but watching it now I still regret like
I mean I do not regret the time I spent
with titanfall 2 I even liked and I put
time aside from fighting felt you to
play the campaign in infinite warfare I
was cool for what it was I'm really
excited for black ops for just because
it seems like they're going for so many
weird things and by weird I mean they're
just trying to branch out into every
genre it's sub-genre in the shooter
space with their battle royale mode
they've got zombies on lock obviously
being Treyarch don't have a campaign but
now they're doing like a titanfall one
kind of campaign like multiplayer only
based around those specialists character
classes they're all aware of that so
it's incorporated into the multiplayer
it's honestly it kind of reminded me of
battle feel one not in the sense that
they're like short stories of each
specialist of each hero benefit one did
something similar where the campaign was
a series of individual story but that
was single-player and I actually really
like those that's I wish I I would love
talking about those back
first came out aside from the Italian
one over here just this wall tonight the
machine gun I really like then it's it's
actually been a fantastic week we were
at call of duty a week ago yeah and now
we're seeing a battlefield reveal sure
it's I've been playing Dark Souls
remastered we got what L says I mean we
have III coming up soon but yeah it's
really slowing down too much um watch
anniversary Rob here's like a really
good pilot just changing subject really
quick and one of the weird things is
that as much as battlefront got crapped
on for their microtransactions their air
game was so good and I wonder
Battlefront 2 to be sorry about a
platoon right and yeah compared to a
little one the air game like the
controls right The Criterion remastered
I guess you could say battlefield 1 2016
16 yeah it was tight it was probably the
best part I thought about Val front 2
was like flying in this interface salt
star fighter assault so here's hoping
that that would be incorporated in 2005
and I for one god I want some runways I
want some like like bases we're like you
could like really you know bottleneck a
team and like eliminate their air their
air game yeah that's that's fun like
that you shouldn't there shouldn't be I
feel like at some point after about
field three people we know spawn camping
and like I think they will call base
rate or wherever that what did whatever
it is where you're like not letting
people get into planes and getting off
the runway that's that's cool though
that's like kind of like when people got
like got afraid of that I feel like the
dream of battlefield games or at least
what they used to be to me was like you
start imagine you were in it for the
long game you weren't just like focus on
spawning killing me be dying and
spawning killing reloading
you jump in and it might take you ten
minutes to get home late that might be
exaggeration it might take you five
actual minutes to get to the next
objective but you spent that you know
going to get into the helicopter and
getting your squad together like moving
to the objective may be like
encountering an objective along the way
like your own thing like it was so it
was all about like that actual real-time
stuff that was playing out and not in
this like it felt less like it was this
arena someone designed to throw you into
and more like you were actually I mean
Oh true to the name it felt like it was
a battlefield that you were kind of it
exploring while you played yeah that's
been one of the issues you mentioned
being a flying in helicopters being a
helicopter pilot and in all the battle
games was kind of a pleasure like just
being a helicopter pilot like not even
necessarily doing anything else yeah and
I was fun day that's doing that the
period the period pieces that were
getting a little run and perhaps World
War two there before helicopters and it
kind of hurts my soul a little bit just
because I miss helicopters yeah I miss
helicopters dude I love being just like
a Hughie transport or like no it wasn't
a Huey in battlefield 3 but I love just
having a couple of Gunners just like
dropping from aircraft carrier to like a
like a flag just drop it off like six
people guys I was exhilarating like [ __ ]
yeah and right now obviously like
battlefield one you're stuck to the
biplanes or the behemoths the Zeppelin
yeah but that's obviously different and
bombers okay what's not sure hi I'm
gonna go to limb and say I would
actually love it if they did the Korean
War I think the Korean War is one of
those where it's like a Forgotten War so
people could actually learn some really
cool stuff it was like a mainly in war
between the United States and China it's
super topical at the moment and it also
took place at sort of the Technology
intersection we had like early
helicopters between World War two and
the Cold War era yeah sure
like World War two rifles good like new
technology like MiG's and yeah I wonder
like obviously I don't think the word
nuclear was being spoken so much at the
time they started making whatever
battlefield 5 is gonna be but like with
today with all this stuff going on in
Korea I wonder how like I mean like
obviously there was good news from Korea
recently but now that seems like you
know like everything is going as it
always had but
and we I wonder like how long people
they want to wait until Korean war is
like can be a game but it's not as its
it's not as you know games make it real
you got Vietnam games that's what I'm
saying like a recent yeah Vietnam would
be more likely I think then than Korea
but like that that throws off my logic
about time because obviously being Isles
more recent but I don't know like yeah
Korean war just have there been any like
hardcore PC sins that have had Korean
War I Monica I don't ever think of that
yeah it feels like it's just one of
those wars that's like completely
forgotten and could be dug in on me like
I love video games and I think video
games can be more than just
entertainment sometimes and like they or
they can both Entertain You and just do
amazing things
yeah so why not cover something in that
you know gives you some some learning
yeah
the game title is a viewer I don't think
I'm actually know this is the uh thing
is the mondragón mm-hmm to be fair world
war one is actually not that well taught
either I know I remember like when I
when we first this was first announced
that I had just I'd every time Daniel
Dwyer was asking questions about World
War one I was like oh I took a whole
semester on just that class and I'd
learned a metric crap-ton because I did
not know much about it before that and
it's crazy how much he World War two is
just pretty much almost inevitable
because of World War one those results
and World War one was just inevitable
because of so many reasons and from a
from a gaming perspective World War one
is also one of those crossroads of
Technology like half the military's
we're just walking around with horses
and carts and like other militaries were
inventing modern warfare and dealing
building cannons I could fire I can't
remember like 60 miles or something
insane the first tanks using the
battlefield I believe are British yeah
the modern it might not be the Marne uh
but yeah it was and at this time in
world war ii world war 1 tanks were
mainly used as troop cover and pushing a
line forward it wasn't until like the
blitzkrieg warfare on germany's part in
world war ii that they really truly
realized the the actual penetration
potential that you can
obviously that was a totally different
kind of warfare from World War one but
yeah it's it would be it would be really
interesting to see what they could do
with like yeah Korea or like going back
to Vietnam again if you haven't listened
to the hardcore history podcasts on
World War one I listen to those on my
commute and it's incredible like there
were so many good little tidbits in
there like most a lot of people in the
war died after they got out of the
trenches and started moving yeah so like
artillery killed most of the people in
World War one and they dug trenches and
I kept them relatively safe yeah and it
wasn't until later in the world when
they had to leave those trenches in
mobile warfare happen that like people
didn't want to leave the trenches I mean
the trenches sucked but they don't want
to leave them because they also kept you
alive
yeah and then no-man's land yeah all
these looks like only one or two of
these maps had no man laughs oh really
in this game yeah I feel like that was
that was always the how do you make
trench warfare oh damn I was at an
assault class don't they have rocket
guns the 80 guns yeah yeah for this
though just joining it about like nine
minutes
we're just playing battlefield one to
kind of get ready for EA and Isis reveal
of battlefield 5 they kind of tease a
little bit with an image earlier this
week and we will again aaron has a lot
of information that he can't talk about
until 2:00 today that's when it's
embargo but we will be showing the
reveal for what about half hour 40
minutes they said they're planning for
then we can talk about what we saw
during the reveal trailer and whatever
else EA and dice show and then at 2 p.m.
Pacific in about an hour and 10 minutes
I'm gonna tell Aaron just to start
telling us what he saw behind the scenes
so we had a lot of battlefield 5 to talk
about today but first and foremost in
about eight minutes we're gonna be doing
the we're gonna be watching the EA
stream so I'm pretty excited about that
we don't know a ton about the game
outside the fact that it's called
battlefield 5 and it's either world war
one world war 2 based on that image and
it will remember came up about world war
ii after Call of Duty went back there
before black ops 4 or went back to the
future again but yeah where I'm flying
around a little bit on the German side
pursue oh geez oh sorry
you forget the button or just for those
you can't see it rob is switching here
between gamepad in okay just take it you
know what are the pilot controls still
that bad I'm mouse and keyboard yeah I
can never do it like I'm not doing this
all day yeah it's just got cranked to
sensitivity and even then you can't hit
anything what yeah what did happen to I
will enjoy sticks growing up oh man what
happened to air games I played I played
so much scarf Star Wars star fighter
with the joystick yeah x-wing valve II
1942 man that was I was my jam
it had some real fun flying in combat
just in general like I don't know I miss
taking off on the runway like the mod
support for 1940 was so friggin good
like there's one mod forgotten hope oh
man
but it was like ultra realistic we had I
did that where you had two likes you you
didn't have infinite amount of bombs you
had to like drop a couple bombs and then
go back to the runway and like basically
land yeah and and rearm that is really
cool I miss like I missed those like
realistic approaches sometimes I don't
feel like lost that sense of patience
that you needed in battlefield games and
I love that because it's gonna like I
said you get in for the long game but
then they just started adopting so many
things that Call of Duty hit popularized
and Call of Duty's popular for a reason
but I want them to go back to that like
non ADHD gameplay that I would really
like to see I mean I'm gonna take that
conversation back to conquest points
losing their meeting what Rob was saying
with you running out of ammo is
something they should have done with
tanks too in battlefield 1 and the
conquest points should have been where
the ammo was it's like I want to drive
2d and that's the tanks bond
I mean Wake Island the Wake Island did
that yeah in battlefield 3 and Wake
Island was from 40 to I believe where
the runway was in the middle of the map
and it was a reason
take that objective that was the runway
yeah at the airplane I was like look
historically accurate - yeah but but
again it serves the purpose of one it
doesn't it doesn't make the tanks
overpowered you have to like at some
point you have to go back and restock
and get the plan around that B and it
gives you a reason to take that
objective and it does it makes it give
the map more character I guess like your
night it's not just this R and this map
where you could run into someone on the
very edge you know what matter as
opposed to an objective you're not just
taking objective or the point you're
taking it like you said to help the rest
of the effort for across multiple things
across Armour across people maybe going
back to get healed maybe people going
back to get more ammo going back to get
shot in the face there's something about
that'll feel one more I feel like you
and then maybe it's just a layout of the
maps I feel like it gets shot in the
back a lot in this game yeah I got agree
with that it's kind of annoying it's one
of those things where more players
doesn't necessarily equal more fun just
depending on how they're used
yeah you brought up operation Metro from
three a while ago and when they put 64
people on that map there's like too many
people on that map yeah it was the ADHD
style you're talking about where there's
more kills is it more fun there's no
scope like it remember that time I shot
those guys and dodging truck yeah Morgan
maybe do a story there's no context
around it that makes it interesting yeah
elephant in the room what do you guys
think you think there's gonna be a
battle royale mode with this following
in the wake of obviously for tonight's
success Oh hub G last year and now call
duty black ops 4 has one dying light is
gonna have that I forget how many
players h1z1 is going to ps4 now you
think battlefield is gonna follow in
those games footsteps I think whoa let
me say this watch it once you do I want
them to yeah I think it's doable more so
than Call of Duty you know I mean like
like look at battlefield it in
comparison to the Call of Duty it's got
that scale it's got vehicles it would be
a smoother transition I think I think
yeah I I think I could I mean if someone
were to ask me which one which one were
to be a better fit I think it's
battlefield would you want them to would
you be okay with it yeah yeah as long as
it was it was a mode not like you know
there
yeah like ham-fisted like this is what
you'll be doing first and foremost as
long as it is just
that you can choose act yeah as long as
it's got like the staples like conquest
and you know you domination and yeah Val
feel three's aftermath had a scavenger
mode which was very similar in style to
Battle Royale
I didn't like I know there are millions
people blame Battle Royale right now and
there's a question as to how many those
games can exist at any one time kind of
over the like hiking for 20 minutes yeah
in one gunfight so if they did go there
I would want something maybe I don't
know what squads are like something a
little bit different that gives me a
chance to not just I mean granted yeah
Battle Royale already has two eyes never
lives but yes something that lets me
play a little bit more shoes like you
get the same tension you deal with that
alrea with Rainbow six siege with like
ten times the amount of actual play time
yeah hey the whole idea battle royale is
just to get you invest it in around and
get your heart pounding by the end of it
that's true you like about it
yeah like even if they just brought in a
mode in battlefield 5 it's like you have
one life I don't know just just permit
that's like like Gears of War Rainbow
six siege obviously a much smaller scale
I'll do that but you have one life just
it makes you want to survive more makes
you work together with people more
something along those lines I would love
as a mode not as the entire game though
her death is is definitely neat I think
that's an aspect like I can be on board
with yeah that was actually good timing
probably don't want to jump in another
match of two minutes left until they
drop the trailer oh really
yeah if their stream starts and uh if
they go right on time showing dolphin
five in exactly two minutes for those
you just joining we were just playing
battlefield one a little bit I'm like my
hardy here with Aaron Sampson and Rob
handler II and we're gonna be seeing the
battlefield 5 livestream trailer or
whatever EA and dice decide to show off
at 2 p.m. Pacific sorry 1 p.m. Pacific
and then right after that we're gonna
break down what we saw talk about what
we are expecting for battlefield 5 based
on that and then again Aaron got jumped
on a call with EA and dice yesterday and
knows a ton about the game that you
can't talk about until 2 p.m. Pacific so
stick around until then so you can hear
some more behind the scenes stuff but
alright
Rob now that you're not playing what are
some
what's one maybe one huge thing that you
want to see them change what they'll
feel five that you didn't really but a
niche that didn't get scratched with
battlefield one a change that I would
want from battlefield well what do you
want battlefield 5 to introduce that
that would make it like hell yeah I'm
back on board with this I'm sure you're
already excited for the game as it is
but what's one thing that would just be
like maybe order the game it seriously
is again I think it's like runways and
and to couple that with like main bases
like the idea of pushing a four so all
the way back to that choke point like
yeah it's not fun to be losing but
that's like that's just the nature of
like battlefield since 1942 like like
seriously like conquest 1942 status even
with like battlefield - with like
generals even you know I mean like that
teamwork that come raw come rock
camaraderie yeah it's just what I would
want I like I missed those days I still
think battlefield one suffers from the
problem just like being a rogue lone
wolf yeah I'm just watching you now I
feel like it lost the sense of the big
picture that made battlefield games so
good like I want to worry about the big
picture about the war effort the battle
like my whole team rather than the next
kill I'm gonna get whether I'm gonna die
in this firefight well I want to worry
about what they're gonna sign this
firefight alright sounds like we're
gonna swap over alright sweet well
here's we're gonna go over to the
battlefield five
[Music]
[Music]
oh thanks Brad you know I've been
playing Battlefield as long as I can
remember
and over the past 16 years these games
have come a long way from 1942 to Bad
Company to Battlefield 4 and up to
Battlefield 1 and today I'm taking on
the most important mission objective
I've ever been a part of telling all of
you about battlefield 5 I'm geared up
ready to go my squads out there so let's
deploy because we are live in London
let's get the show started
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
welcome everyone to the battlefield 5
live reveal I'm your host for this
evening Trevor Noah and I'm so excited
to be here introducing this new edition
of battlefield which for some reason
everyone has really assumed is
battlefield 5 I mean and not battlefield
V could be V why not v battlefield V
could be just as good yeah I do love
that fans on Twitter actually changing
the V's in their profiles for this game
something my mother did many years ago
ahead of the curve and most people don't
know this but the V and my name is
actually a 5 yeah my name is actually
pronounced Trev 5 or Noah very unique as
a huge fan of these games I've always
loved how captivating the battlefield is
and today you'll see that battlefield 5
has the most immersive battlefield ever
if you've ever been in a battle with me
you know that I'm the most dedicated
support class you will ever meet I'm in
the mud repairing the tanks you know I'm
laying down mines as tank rushes come in
one time I even repaired a plane midair
that might be alive but I'm sticking
with it because you see I love that
glorious joy of being the uncelebrated
hero in a battle and this game is going
to have tons of moments like that there
are so many new and exciting features
coming to you in battlefield 5 that you
will learn about today the next level of
large-scale multiplayer battlefield 5
single-player war stories and we'll
start showing you the epic post-launch
journey all players will experience when
the game is finally released
and you know we've got some other
surprises so why waste time let's get
straight into it and get the show
started I'm joined now by the producers
of battlefield 5 andreas morel ryan
macarthur and loves Gustafson everybody
see
I'm not here as a professional anything
I am here as a gamer I am here as a
battlefield player I'm here to ask only
the questions I am interested in you
have made a horrible mistake at the
beginning you are taking players back to
where the battlefield French I started
World War two now at this point are you
are you like those guys you know those
elderly pilots that they find out an
island in the Pacific you know who think
that the war never ended is that who you
are right now it did you told me we had
to break it to you two fellows go back
to that now to be honest with you it's
really I mean we joined four years to go
back to where it all started in about 16
years ago and you know technology has
evolved them the team has gotten gained
so much experience that this is really
the game we wanted to build them that we
did it's really something the the guys
back home at dice is really passionate
about the whole era just ask mr.
battlefield he was he was there mr.
battlefield that's was his nickname by
the way I'm known as madam battlefields
now player players have experienced
World War two in in so many movies and
in games it's really difficult to come
up with a new and fresh perspective what
perspective are you bringing to it with
this version of Battlefield andreas will
this be more Saving Private Ryan or
inglorious basterds so we've seen all
the movies you know we play the games
we've been there I'm I'm pretty sure at
least I can navigate half of France with
our months just by playing the game so
so for us going back to to where it all
began for us it's really about
delivering World War 2 experience that
no one's ever never seen before really
can i hitting on the unseen locations to
untold stories there unplayed moments
yeah I mean for us it's really taking
you on the journey from the start and at
a go you will be able to play the German
forces the British forces and we want to
take you on that journey you know to
exotic places like and freezing
Scandinavia it's gonna bones are but in
Norway or or ragged deserts where the
battles took place in northern Africa
yeah why not today the ruins of the once
a beautiful Rotterdam so it's really to
take you on a journey and we want to do
this with a kind of a fresh and modern
take
and so really hopefully surprise to
players but also to please them you've
given me a sneak peek and so many words
come to my mind I mean intense immense
powerful Ryan do you have a specific way
that you want players to see this
battlefield well I think the best way we
can describe it is immersive I mean this
this needs to feel like the most
immersive battlefield that the players
have ever played I mean we want them to
exploit the battlefield in ways they've
never been able to before I mean when
you look at the chaotic multiplayer that
the franchise is known for and sort of
fan classics like conquest and some of
the new modes that the guys are working
on like airborne you know we're going
back with the war story sort of that
anthology storytelling that we had we
built in the f1 and telling new stories
about men and women that change history
I mean we get to tell everyone say that
the coop is back in battlefield five and
that's a huge thing for us and this is
just the beginning I mean launch is just
the beginning for this game and we
really want to take players on a journey
through World War two it always feels
like it's a journey that's what it
always feels like with battlefields like
one thing I loved about the game was how
the maps in the world was constantly
changing you know I felt like my bedroom
at home I never knew what to expect and
I think when looking at this game
andreas what's your vision to take this
to the next level so we're really
building on what we started with
previous games it's it's really about
giving players the most immersive world
of the kill enter you should really be
grounded in its expanding on the
movement said the way we're done so well
really pushing all these new features
that we're gonna be talking about right
it sounds great
I'm genuinely excited I have a few
highlights that I'm looking forward to
let's dive into it and talk about some
of the gameplay he had to do that is
Daniel Berlin a battlefield 5 we're
expanding the toolbox for the player
giving you access to new abilities to
create your own and brand new
battlefield moments now there's a deeper
connection between the player and the
world around you you will be physically
pushed by the shockwave from explosions
you can experience completely new ways
to traverse and tactically maneuver
across the battlefield we
our overhauled movement system our
renowned destruction will rip up the
terrain live chunks of masonry hanging
from destroyed buildings or have
high-caliber rounds ripped straight
through walls to take out two enemies
hiding inside we're also bringing back
classic modes such as majority rule
conquest but we also have new modes and
experiences for our unique take on world
war 2 we're bringing back operations
with a bang and we're calling it grand
operations here you'll experience
multiple game modes as you fight over
multiple maps all wrapped with an hour
narrative journey through historically
inspired battles from world war ii with
the return of our anthology formats for
singer play war stories with new
characters to meets and untold stories
to discover back to each other
now Daniel just talked about a new
multiplayer experience called grand
operations and I'm really excited
because it sounds to me like you can
pilot a giant grand piano like a tank
I'm pretty certain that's what it is
right and dress I'm not sure about the
piano but it's definitely massive it's
it's really about really being all these
power fantasies from world war ii like
airborne being power dropped in and its
operations from battlefield one but big
it's really good yeah I mean what we
want players to feel like a sort of a
dynamic player impacted experience take
taking place over for fictional days I
mean day one starts with you jumping out
of an airplane and with the objective to
to destroy the enemy artillery with that
M&E sort of entrenching themselves to
defend and protect and depending on how
the outcome of day one goes for you as
the two as the two main forces start to
battle over day two in a game of
breakthrough with a number of lives you
have left remaining depending on what
you did the day before and then as you
continue to push on into new locations
we're gonna see things like conquest
assault where players continue to fight
for that terrain and assuming you know
when we see these these players end up
in a giant stalemate then they're gonna
enter day 4 which is final stand and I
mean this is this is sort of tired muddy
no resources left you've got just you
your squad and one and one clip and you
all fight to the last man standing with
the weight of the world on your
shoulders so this is a game mode that
you may never see if your games are not
in a stalemate you may never get to that
fourth map and fourth story then exactly
that's an exciting way to play the game
I want to know when we can see more of
that two weeks
airplane Los Angeles you get hands-on
multiplayer for the first time if you're
there so even the reveal of grand
operations spans across multiple events
Wow alright I have to say I heard you
guys say that co-op is back and that's
one of my favorite aspects of
battlefield one laws can you tell me
more about that mode I definitely can I
mean I'm happy to say that for the first
time since battlefield 3 co-op is back
and we're calling it two combined arms
and here it's jet another way to
experience that
field samples you know next to our war
stories and the multiplayer and what we
want to do here is to allow you and up
to three players to go online and step
into those shoes of the Pathfinders
those paratroopers that go in behind
enemy lines and here you really only
have to soldier next to you as you move
forward since you know getting detected
might mean death and you will soon be
struck by resource scarcity you need to
find the tools and find your way to the
objective so stakes are high and you
need to kind of assess can I push
through or do we need to extract our
leads it's kind of win or lose it's up
to you
I've been a huge fan of war stories the
single-player campaign in battlefield
one what I what I truly enjoyed about it
was I felt like I was learning about the
stories behind the war and playing
through the stories of the war and it
didn't always end well and what I loved
is because of that history elements like
I for instance I told my little brother
I said hey if mom ever catches you
playing just say this is a history class
that you're doing on the console and
then what I'll do is I'll tell my mom he
was gonna do that so she would know that
I was always her favorites and what was
great was seeing the story laws like how
a single player gonna change in
battlefield 5 don't tell this to my kids
art needs changing I mean to me I'm
happy that you like the war stories and
for us their stories are really our
opportunity to put the war into
perspective it's really about this human
and untold stories of the war and we try
to portray those kind of real and
relatable people facing epic warfare and
it's it's battlefield after all so we'll
be talking a lot to you today about the
gameplay improvements so play your
agency is key so you can create your own
battlefield moments and at the bottom
line it's about allowing you to witness
the Second World War but through the
eyes of the men and women that changed
the world
I mean as you can see here I mean this
is one of the war stories that we're
gonna be talking about first I mean this
is our North East story this is the
story of a young woman who is part of
the Norwegian resistance fighters
fighting the German occupation during
World War two
I mean this is an exploration of emotion
and fee
it's a family story yeah you know and
this not only sort of really grounds the
players in the reality but sort of sets
the context of the world war two that
we're trying to create at dice it's not
often that you find stories that connect
with the emotion of the characters in
the story and instead of just focusing
on the explosions in the gunfire you see
that look in her eyes you want to know
what she's thinking what she's
experiencing in that story why was it so
important for you to focus on the people
behind the stories from war well I think
it's it's important to tell you know
sort of believable in sort of honest
stories and really sort of set the
context and sort of main that maintain
that connection to the world that we're
trying to create I think it's important
for for people to understand where we're
coming from and what our what our
particular take is on world war two so
what we got to do right now is we're
gonna go back to Daniel now to cover
what you'll take to the battlefield with
you
in battlefield five we're aiming to
mirror the immense arsenal of the Second
World War this was a period that saw an
explosion in terms of innovation when it
comes to weapons and vehicles you will
get to fly iconic airplanes engage in
incredible tank battles and also unleash
secret weapons from world war ii weapons
that are powerful enough to turn the
tide of any battle and with the new
fortification system you can be more
strategic than ever in how you choose to
defend or advance fuga terrain back to
you guys
you know in clean battlefields I know
everyone in the audience will agree with
me people at home as well I've always
been impressed by the level of realism
in the game I remember once I was
playing with a friend whose certain
Special Forces and we were talking about
our favorite guns and I was talking
about the recoil and what I liked about
the sights versus other guns and he
turned to me at one point he said oh
where did you serve and I felt
embarrassed cuz I was like all
battlefield 3 that's that's where I was
and instead of him being angry he was
like I didn't know that it was a game
that was that immersive something that
really was as true to real without being
a war simulation as possible guys tell
me about some of your favorite weapons
in the game some of the new vehicles
that will be available in battlefield 5
I think
first just by going back to this era we
can the pool of hardware that we can
choose from is immense there's so much
there and for me being a vehicle guy
it's really quite simple choice it's the
tiger one it's a tech one tear I think
it's the most iconic tank from this era
I just think it's amazing what what do
you what do you like about it that's a
weird choice for me have you seen it I
think is the best
what like the looks a bit but also
checking out a tank in a battle with
that yeah but I've never looked at it
I'm like if I'm on the outside I'm dying
if I'm on the inside I'm concentrating
when are you looking
what are you doing this detroy
third-person camera and just run around
the tank dying and there was gonna be
like who's that guy looking at the tank
it's come on it's beautiful I'll take
your word for it yeah so undressed as a
tank guy mr. battlefield laws how about
you we've been trying to hide it the
fact that I'm also support plane I can't
hit the barn from the inside so I need
the big flips and for me the mg42 is
really the weapon I play in the place
right my man it has that iconic sound
that you know sense fear all over the
map and and they're not a part of it is
the new kind of system which Daniel
talked about for a high caliber weapons
so previously I could make the same
impact as a pistol preowned basically
but this time around it comes with a
punch so where the pistol gets stuck in
the wall I can rip through so
I can finally make a difference on the
battlefield hashtag no more knocking
elections all right so we can wait Hank
guy we've got a weapons guy Ryan well
sort of embarrassing them it's unlike
Lars I can hit a bar in period so for me
it's the toolbox invalid one all players
had a gas mask and B F about the fight
we're gonna replace that gas mask for
the toolbox so that means I can run
around the battlefield with my toolbox
setting up fortifications and and sort
of really change in the dynamic of the
battlefield so that these guys who can
actually hit something I can offer offer
some valium in the playing field what
wait so fortifications you just skimmed
over that but what is what is
fortifications well I mean this as like
as a support weapon I think this is this
is something you're really love is
something I I think is a great addition
to the game it really allows you to sort
of players want to focus on the
objective I mean this is this is
something you can sort of pull out your
toolbox you can you build reinforcements
you can reinforce buildings that Andres
has destroyed with this tank you can
build foxholes and set up machine guns
so people like Lars can sit there and
camp out at choke points I mean this is
going to change the strategic way people
pay both as attackers and defenders is
that was that in response to the gaming
community because I know as a
battlefield gamer I always wanted what I
didn't have so first I was going hey
guys I need destruction
I need places to fall apart and then at
some point was like too much destruction
too much destruction I like there's
nothing left was this a response yeah I
mean we've had a lot of esteemed players
in here in the studio today and in the
community overall who at some point
especially when we're testing how we
came to a point where the level was
level was level then you couldn't
advance so basically this is to counter
that and give you an additional kind of
toolbox to to rebuild and then you and I
can come in as heroes again and they
fortify we come down and we add an
addiction extra I have a machine gun or
an a a gun so it's kind of teamwork once
again and we are to celebrate adherence
we have a celebrated hero heroes we
deserve to be thank you now now that
we've learned about the tools let's hear
about of the company here to tell us
more please welcome Natalie
yeck
ever and yes the company is something
that is completely new to battlefield 5
it's your personal collection of
customized soldiers weapons and vehicles
that you can tailor and grow as you play
the company is the heart and soul of
your personal experience and the choices
you make here for your company actually
matters not only with your choices
affect the way you look but also how
your weapons and vehicles play as you
squat up with your friends make sure to
pick a soldier that complements the rest
of your squad to take on the battle
ahead and during the game adapt to the
change in circumstances by chat by
calling your company and bring in the
right soldier weapon or vehicle to suit
your situation back to your trevor
andreas that really sounds awesome tell
me more about the company and how it
works because you know I know from my
years in battlefield that the group that
rarely plays together stays together
now the company is something that we
super excited about for first time you
can now create your own personal
experience with the soldiers to take
onto the battlefield it's really up to
you to decide how you want them to play
and also how they how they look so as
you keep playing and you get better your
soldiers will get better with you so
give me an example of how this would
impact me as a support class so if you
take your support class whether you want
you start playing with that with that
with that soldier and you start
progressing you're gonna unlock you know
a set of new abilities new perks and
sort of these new exotic ways to play
the game as a support class and then you
know unlock new weapons for yourself to
play with you take that machine gun that
Lars loved so much and you level that
machine gun up you make the choices that
matter and then you decide well I think
this needs its own custom paint job so
you sort of make that machine gun really
make it your own and then you go in and
you grab that that sort of iconic
support outfit that you really want to
wear going in the bottle you jump in
with some friends and off you go you
know it's funny you brought up
customization because I've always
believed in battlefield the team is
important but looking badass is the most
important thing I think anyone who's
been in war can agree with this
please tell me that I can customize my
look to be properly badass in the
battlefield well yeah of course I mean
if it's worth doing it's worth doing
looking good right so I think you know
part of the tactical gameplay that comes
with battlefield I mean what we want to
do is give you the ability to create
your own personal identity so you know
no more anonymous soldiers you know this
is your soldiers and their boots
going into battle their own weapons
customized the way that you want to do
it the gear that you want them to wear I
mean this is this is gonna feel like
it's your own personal Arsenal and
obviously I want to get as much of that
Arsenal as I can possibly get how do I
even begin getting all of this gear you
play the game I mean for what we want
players is you get rewarded for playing
the game yeah I mean it's pretty short
it's whatever you want to progress
towards your company your class or a
specific items you play the game and we
set out to commit to that you'll always
feel rewarded for what you do whatever
you play she just played you to unlock
these items then I guess I have to ask
and I know it's a sensitive subject but
I'm still gonna go there is this game
going to be pay to win
no you can't pay to get an on for game
play advantage what it might have a lot
of money no so in battlefield it's
always been about a balance rock paper
sister game play and it's still this you
really have to like less for saying you
have to play the game at a new gear and
skill is really key okay but what about
premium pass will it be one of those
games where I have to shell out another
50 bucks
six months after I've bought the game is
that how it works well I guess I guess I
get the fun part of not taking any more
of your money as well but no there's no
more premium pass in this game this
means
I mean this means no we're paying for
maps no more paying for modes you know
this is some of the community has asked
for this is something the team really
believes and so what we want is a game
where people stay together they play the
games together and they get to go on
this journey through world war two
together that's beautiful that means I
finally lose my nickname no Maps Noah
alright well it's time to learn about
what happens after the game launches so
to tell us all about live service please
welcome back Natalie and Daniel the
launch is really just the beginning
title war is an epic journey that you
and your company will take through World
War two it will bring you an evolving
diverse game that will grow over time as
we immerse you and your company in
different theatres of war playing
battlefield 5 is an experience unlike
any other it will differ from all
previous Battlefield games and the most
important thing it's open to all players
yes and there will always be new battles
new France and rewards on the horizon
and by removing premium pass we are
keeping the community together so this
time there will be no exam expansion
packs and all players will be able to
take part in the same journey through
battlefield 5 and we types of war our
players will experience theme chapters
of World War 2 each spanning over
several months and these will focus on
key moments that impact the outcome of
the conflict Trevor this sounds to me
like a wild full ride through World War
two but laws like how big of a journey
will this be long it's a straight no I
mean to put it into perspective this was
a world war and I mean to me it's gonna
be a huge journey I mean we want to take
you on that journey with chapters from
the history and at the end of it we
really want you to be kind of
experiences daily weekly and monthly
events leading up to you kind of the
pinnacle of the grand operations and
experience to achieve those special
assignments get
treated with extra rewards so so it is
about keeping it fresh and constantly
evolving since what we see here and
talked about here today's it's just just
the beginning and as you play it through
you start to be taken to new horizons
new locations new gameplay and I mean
stake in for the ride it sounds like
it's gonna be one of those experiences
where the more I play the more cool
stuff I can get I get rewarded for my
time is that gonna be across different
modes it's again it's really simple you
just have to play the game to a new cool
high and doesn't matter if it's
multiplier or combined-arms like like
you see here you will be able to earn
new vehicles new weapons it's gonna be
dog tags and soldier skins weapon skin
it's all there to really customize your
your crew to really be standing out on
the battlefield the way you want it to
be right it sounds amazing and I only
have one question and that is when does
this all starts well the game launches
in October so starting November running
through early 2019 we're gonna start
with our first chapter which is gonna
focus on the fall of Europe so we're
gonna we're gonna explore so the German
mechanized war machine as it pushes its
way into Europe this is gonna be live
gameplay focused events we're gonna have
themed attic rewards tied to this you
know we can't wait to talk to the
community more about this between as we
lead up to launch yeah I'm not gonna lie
you guys have definitely raised my
analog stick and I think we've waited
long enough this is the most immersive
battlefield yet in a world war two you
have never seen before
we're launch is just the beginning of
the journey I'm done talking I think
it's time we see this thing are you you
already
well here it is lady determined the
first time ever the reveal trailer for
battlefield
5
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
hello friends
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
gameplay best Xbox one Wow Wow
the car the thing the man the boo you
saw the thing man
uh-huh I hope they got insurance that
was insane do you see that that was a
dress I don't feel like you saw I feel
like you've seen it before jumped on
their back and there started shooting
while moving on their back yeah it's
cool inside this is what happens when
you live life in a tank Andreas before
we go before we go am I correct in
saying there were some new animations
there were some new moves that you could
you could do in the game there's a few
yeah okay thank you I think we should
thank the team back home eh Colin
helping us to get to this point I think
they are truly amazing and our fans
again we've been waiting for this moment
for so long to be able to reveal what
we've been working on this is really
packed with gameplay and I mean a lot of
days this is direct feedback from
community leading to a lot of these
improvements so it's a huge thank you
for for the support and once again the
team for doing a extraordinary up as
always an impression the look on your
face you know in kids the mark they're
going for him yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean
I'm excited I'm excited give it up for
the people in Stockholm
Wow Wow
battlefield 5 launches worldwide on
October 19th in the meantime these guys
are giving away free expansion packs in
battlefield 1 and battlefield 4 so just
head to battlefield comm for all the
details and next up is EA play on June
9th where you'll see multiplayer for the
very first time I hope all of you are as
excited as I am for Battlefield 5 to
watch that trailer again go to
youtube.com forward slash Battlefield
and if you want more info join some of
the team here with Xbox who are hosting
an exclusive post show on mixer comm 4 /
Xbox that is our show for tonight
thank you so much for joining us
everybody I'm Trevor Noah good night
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
so we just saw the battlefield 5 reveal
from EA and dice
we got chance to I don't know I was kind
of underwhelmed a little bit with what
they showed but again III is right
around the corner so they did give us a
taste World War 2 confirmed it's
official we have a lot to talk about but
I want to start off with that are you
guys pretty are you happy about the
world war 2 returning to that or you did
you like I don't know what do you even
want I'm stoked I mean I wanted World
War C so bad always 1942 is like one of
my all-time favorite games it was when
my parents told me I had a problem was
that game like it was like get off the
computer it's like I was in a clan like
I love the air game so I'm super excited
for that I think it's natural to go from
world war 1 to world war ii mean would
we you know what would you want like
it's they and honestly like even two
years ago right about the old one came
out that's what I wanted was World War
two right um it was a cool change of
pace in a way to go somewhere new and
front like refreshing right like oh whoa
no one who's ever seen that represented
a game I think that was pretty neat but
you're kind of limited like we've talked
about before like battlefield one was
kind of a world war 2 game I know what I
mean in my as well but it was like
semi-autos like area air combat in in
World War 1 was never that intensive I
don't even think they used blimps to
that degree and things weren't just like
mobile cover they were actual like
battle tanks in belleville one yeah and
we're ultimately just used for trenches
and we're a snail's pace right so they
kind of got away with it I think here
it's like full-on you've been testing
the waters now as time is has gone by
for so long right like so other things
here but yeah like I think yeah well you
try to bring up the trailer I do laughs
while we're talking my world war ii i
want to mention the tides of war is what
they're calling it so the game released
in october we don't know the official
date yet they are they didn't announce
it then but in november starting
November they're gonna be there their
post release support is there's no
premium pass at all they also said
there's no pay to win so there still
could be cosmetic items and stuff which
I'm assuming there will be because which
is like fine yeah and obviously they're
there
to be like cosmetic items that you can
probably pay more because you're
building at your company and we can get
to that but tides of war seems super
interesting so this is like seasons or
operations in Rainbow six siege or like
any number of games that do post release
like seasons like this
Diablo starter obviously did a lot of it
but you're gonna be going through the
the war itself so starting in November
it will be Aaron I know again it's tough
for you because you've known a lot more
about this if you're watching now we
have a lot more information coming out
to that we saw behind closed doors
yesterday but right now based on what
they said what do you think of this kind
of this kind of a the way that they're
releasing post content yeah Taizo war
sounds really interesting so getting rid
of the premium past is actually really
big now they got to be careful because
they did that with battlefront and that
blew up in their face because of the
types of micro transactions that they
put in afterwards
yeah so I if as long as they've learned
their lessons from that game and you
could you could hear him saying in the
stream yeah there's no pay to win which
is I think his way of saying everything
is going to be cosmetic yeah but what
did premium ever do like it cost players
who are dedicated to the game a ton of
money like you had to buy it for every
single console divided up the player
base okay so let's get right to it so if
you're watching we have a crap ton of
[ __ ] that they didn't show during that
at all okay
so Aaron yesterday he was they were
behind the scenes with EA and dice what
are some quick bullet points not quick
we have some time we'll release day for
one so this is all new release date
October okay so open beta later this
year
October 11th is the play first trial for
EA access on is that just xbox they they
just said origin they did not say Xbox
so we're assuming that it's only just
origin okay if you look at anything like
yeah battlefield 1 it's it sounds like
the exact same role yeah like we're
gonna have we're gonna see the first map
probably on map like San Quinn scarf or
Rothfeld lon okay and the at e3 excuse
me and then soon after that maybe in
July is wouldn't I think it was for B if
one will be the open beta that people
could probably dot it okay so I'm
assuming October 11th and then what is
the is the release date they just said
on the stream
November's gonna be the first DLC so
there's gonna be a DLC within one month
of launch
I'm sorry within within one month of
their EA early access launch for the
deluxe edition is October 16th so I do
wonder if they won't sneak in some of
the premium costs into that edition but
it's only a couple days ahead of the
standard edition which is October 19th
so that's the official release date
technically October 19th of this year
battlefield 5 releases so yeah open beta
then October 11th play first trial
October 16th deluxe edition October 19th
standard edition cool November 1st DLC
so let's probably bring it back to kind
of the title what we can look
the ear is the season of
[Applause]
they talk a lot about Norway
yes
we'll go to Le at some point too then
they're gonna be showing all these
everything so could I find more
interesting about their times of war is
that what they talked a lot about
yesterday was
[Music]
[Applause]
currencies and then you keep it like
okay so that's almost like that's kind
of again like rainbows succeed with a
weapon attachments that are used to be
now it's different but and yet
mentioning customization we got
something talking about your ability you
know not just one character or like four
classes you're building out an entire
company and one minor thing they're not
minor thing but one thing they didn't
really touch on was that this is the
first time you play you have playable
women in battlefield game it's pretty
cool he had a [ __ ] cloth
she killed like 12 people so she seems
badass but you've really got an entire
company
this is cosmetic items this is your they
said you liked building classes within
that company so that it sounds like it's
a collection of loadouts if I'm not
mistaken but you can customize their
appearance as well so there is the full
range of customization this time around
so you can customize all of your
characters like helmets face paint arms
jackets we saw like a cosmic that like
that one jacket I wish we had a picture
of it [ __ ] oh yeah so much going off
the most cliched 1940s I love it so much
I only got one shoulder shoulder holster
yeah I got one kill and died but man did
he look good yeah all of your characters
can be male or female so you can you can
pick gender you can also pick weapon
customization so like in the trailer you
saw a muzzle break you mean that that
mg42 had like camo I want to say leaves
on the barrel that was debris from the
explosion
oh maybe was just like it was camo it
was okay cool sweet awesome and so
customize all your weapons more like
battlefield 3 yeah the weapons by the
way now have actual recoil too so they
cost a lot about their guns in this game
when you fire the weapon
like jump up and down
[Applause]
like the recoil
[Applause]
is there gonna be long
they didn't see but it's always been a
stable sure yeah I imagine that would be
the case so you have talked about
customization folders and classes and
weapons we talked about that
types of we talk yeah you mentioned
Norway it was pretty cool like it seems
like they're going for those forgotten
campaigns but do you want to talk about
gameplay stuff cuz you said that when
they were talking to us or about that
trailer the trailer was meant maybe in
like subtle ways the trailer it seemed
like an action movie to me but it was a
teaser and again III swear I went around
the corner I'm sure we'll see more but
the trailer showed a bunch of things
that you noticed that I didn't because
you saw a lot of behind the scenes
information you noticed a few things in
the trailer specifically the way squads
were working and how she respawned back
on him can you talk about that yeah and
in a second I think we're gonna try and
grab the trailer I literally like have a
page and a half on just that trailer
okay but I know John Luke has it up why
don't we just kind of slowly enter way
through it because because Aaron is you
know despite that being clearly not
straight gameplay with no scripted and
there was HUD on it but as to reiterate
again there are there are things that
trailers representing that you can do in
the game it's it yeah so while we just
run it so there's a horse head okay can
we just stop at times okay yeah so this
is a let's go a little bit further so
this is a horse head statue you see like
teddy bears and lute this is very likely
tank customization it's probably part of
their live service so they have like
timed events where you think the tank is
difficult trophies and ornaments for
tanks yeah oh yeah gold ornament that's
it customized Eagle Eagle Claw I'm gonna
be the most ridiculous flamboyant
looking person hell yeah baby by the way
so that explosion in the hallway was
showing the physics in the game so you
see some of this in battlefield one but
it blows and the chandeliers fly
everywhere that's part of their like
destruction system and you'll see it in
a second again with the tank where the
tank goes through the house and they
mentioned that you yourself the player
will get blown away like a few feet
right yeah so you'll you'll see a lot of
stuff that I loved from like bad company
where there's like dirt in your face and
you're getting rocked by explosions yeah
so their tanks been disabled they run in
the house we immediately see
customization here you have the your
female protagonist this is multi player
by the way she's got a hook hand you see
like face paint war paint dope jacket
dope jackets they immediately go into
close quarters combat by the way she's
British and she's rocking a Thompson SMG
he's got a silencer a suppressor of some
sort on his yeah so go back you missed
that part header that right here on the
left bullets are coming through the
walls so this is a new feature in the
game whereas before you can only shoot
through doors in battlefield 1 or remove
the whole wall with the tank right like
bullet like contextual bullet holes is
pretty big so it's even more like maybe
like Rainbow six siege
so that LMG is in particular can go
through walls which is really cool you
can just rate walls we think there's
people in there this guy is in a new
down but not out state so in the revive
system yeah yeah that so in battlefield
2 everything is based around your your
squad so when you go down you go into an
over-the-shoulder of your squad mates
and you never get kicked back to the
orbital screen unless your entire squad
gets wiped out so um hold on a second do
we see what's on his back right now he's
got a [ __ ] samurai yeah okay sick so
down Bernard out state you have two
buttons that you can press one of them
is call for health and one of them is
give up okay
this gets even crazier because actually
now people in your squad can revive you
not just the medic everybody everybody
can revive
you bet so cool they can't give you
house only the medic can give you health
and only the medic can revive people
outside of your squad that's cool okay
so everything right now keeps you in
your school also it's funny when the
lady got shot of the banding and went
down that was what she was in the down
but not out stage she wasn't actually
dead
okay also I know if you mentioned that
apparently you can drag or did you say
that away I was yes yeah so this is huge
so I liked it to think of you know the
reed live system incorporated with this
new mechanic is that this is confirmed
they're gonna do this yeah they're going
to allow players to drag and pull a
downed player like to but like behind
cover and then you know administer a
rival because if you're not a medic it's
gonna take you a lot longer you're gonna
want to get your downed player out of
the line of fire if that makes sense you
can drag down players which is so cool
like I always want to be able to drag
players behind cover before reviving
yeah John Luke will have to go all the
way back to the house so we're just
gonna call out a lot of stuff in here we
see a little bit further back we see an
execution from behind and the player
comes up the stairs so that's returning
is the the like instant execution from
behind then we look over this dude looks
out the window and we see a tank rolling
on the house this trailers free with
destruction so this is part of their no
Luud movements horse nose go back yeah
yeah talk about this this is really cool
okay so in battlefield one is super
awkward you run up to Windows and you
got a whack at them with your shovel and
hopefully get through no more so now you
run up two objects you press a button
and you do things like leap through
second-story windows enroll this is an
actual feature in the game this is the
rear prone so the develop the developers
love perón they like talked about this
for half the time so you can now fall on
the ground and crawl backwards or like
fall on the ground and slide sideways
and there's full 360 degree movement
from the prone position so you can do
this you can crawl backwards and shoot
or like run and slide and crawl
backwards and shoot so this this like
running and jumping on a window and rear
sliding that's all in multiplayer and
we're like I don't know if you could do
this but Emagine like doing a rear prone
jump down a stairway you're
backwards like Trinity crashing through
that window and the fence exactly right
Hugo Weaving chasing you there's
something right there through the
background the towing so we're not even
done with that scene back this is this
is so Private Ryan by the way burns ed
burns or so the tank coming through the
house they have a new destruction system
on houses so it's not candid all that
has physics when a tank goes through a
house all the debris will go in the
direction that the tank goes but they
also said there's crazy stuff like if a
tank shell hits a house it'll blow it
but if a tank shell goes through a
window and blows inside the house that's
a different type of explosion and it'll
blow stuff like out of the house out of
the back of the house so and after this
house is destroyed then we're gonna get
into the fortification system where
players can then rebuild that house with
sandbags
so here's light vehicles stop right here
so that is the tow yeah this is so sorry
go okay so as part of the fortification
system teams have headquarters and in
those headquarters there are tanks and
things that you can tow so like what is
this like an 88 flat gun sure so you can
go to the back of the base go hook up
like a flat gun to a tank and drive off
and your buddy can be in the flat gun
shooting while you're driving right so
that's so cool because you have people
building up these fortifications which
we'll see in a second and then if you
get if your team gets like held up on a
fortification you can go back to your
headquarters grab a buddy and a flak gun
and go like reduce it right so cool
which also means you're never gonna know
where the flak guns are on the map
because people can't own I mean if you
can imagine - if this is like a towing
feature whether it's at launch or down
the road you could probably tell other
things right lever takeoff and landing
planes maybe if they're gonna introduce
that like oh hello movement aspect we
hope I mean like yeah I like or like a
glider like you know like it's like a
like like d-day invasion where they had
gliders with like jeeps and stuff and
yeah and those things like that could be
something down the road like if that's a
if that's a prominent feature right like
this towing mechanic that tank also had
like a with logs track the side which is
more cost
yeah so yeah you brought this up this is
you know there's there's an event
happening maybe and this is you know if
you can measure the big the middle of
the map if this is a LEvolution type
thing or the bridge blows like this
seems to be very pronounced action here
right like jeeps and vehicles flying off
of the bridges here so they didn't
specifically say a LEvolution but in
concept art we've seen this bridge hole
yeah so I think there's a good chance
that was a LEvolution event if you go
back just real quick to the plane
crashing and the dude getting thrown
messerschmitt bf-109 by the way so this
is yeah oh so this is likely physics in
the game again this is this is a
representative trailer like we haven't
actually played the game so I can't
confirm any of this hands-on but the do
getting tossed and then the airplane
lands and the pilot gets out if this is
in the game and I'm not confirming this
part because I didn't talk about planes
but that'd be sick if you could crash in
the little crush land in this game and
laughs yeah baby
dude that that's a that's a really
strong point because that is something
that is I would say has never been done
before
like and that's also in Aeryn we talked
about this like to death which is like
in a lot of BALCO games I would say
arguably since for there have there has
been a separation of error game and
ground game where you feel a little
disjointed you're just doing some
strafing runs and then you're getting
shot down eventually by more or less
another pilot than any pilot here
opposed to just like ejecting like you
could you could have this intense moment
of like crash landing right yeah if you
don't have a shoot or something like
that like that could be that could be
really fun like I don't know I hope
that's in the game so let's stop here
and here's that camouflaging mission
yeah let's go back to the gun on the
ground so there's a lot going on in this
shot here so first of all this is part
of the scarcity system so everything in
this game is tied into getting players
to play objectives which is something we
talked about being a problem earlier so
the fortifications get you attached to
actually defending points and then the
squad system has you and actually Rob
you mentioned this before you have to
spot or sorry you join a game in a squad
where then you have to choose to go solo
yeah so you get you run out of ammo on
this game this game has ammo scarcity
you act
you run out of ammo between lives you
don't get your ammo back all your ammo
back when you spawn so this that's cool
this gun that got picked up there's only
ten bullets in it
so immediately a person no ten out of 50
sorry ten nine fifty so like maybe one
drum right right so this person
immediately needs a support class person
around or they need to get to an
objective to pick up ammo this does look
like conquest assault by the way with
the tickets on top and they're you know
they're trying to take a couple of
points a B and C okay so they pick up a
gun it only has like one drum of ammo in
it stop here we can see the
fortification system in the game so this
is a capture control point those
sandbags are in the game so there's the
players are they're physically building
this fortification on a control point
and that's something that everyone can
do is build what's the list you can
build sandbags you can put up boards
trim these trenches or wire was it tank
teeth yeah so is that for like anti
mines and stuff like that is that the
idea between behind tank teeth yeah just
off to actual for fication it's not
something piranha tank guy so these are
at set points on the map they didn't did
they're not like completely dynamic they
are at they've had all the major control
points on the map we see a flat gun that
probably got alright sorry I know it's
our kin independent toad up there yeah
we see an engineer with like a with a
rocket but so this is real this is in
the game and this is being built by
players while they're playing and that
was something they in that stream they
touched on which was one of I think one
of the gripes or problems with Bal
killed one was that again let's and quit
quitting San Quentin scar thank you God
yeah we mention this when you were
playing earlier yeah like like there are
moments where you know say the behemoth
comes in because the other team is just
getting stomped on comes in like halfway
through the the match and can just level
the entire town so when you're going to
try to cap a flag you don't have any
obstacles our cover around you you're
just prone and everyone could see you so
that's that's what they're kind of
offering as a solution right is like
putting up these fortifications really
like
instead of saying let's decrease
destruction they're like no let's keep
destruction as well as it was if not
increasing on it but let's give people a
chance to reverse it if they want it if
they so choose
it does likes to support classes have
more rebuilding options or is everybody
pretty much like sandbag capable so what
they said was anybody can build okay um
but you can also specialized classes in
this game now so it's possible that as a
support class you may be able to build
more than and I'm speculate and I tanks
that have a sort of cooldown right yeah
vehicle were build faster I don't know
yeah that's very likely the only the
only specific specialization they
actually said as an example was an
assault class who could specializes
anti-tank which actually could at be it
was one thing that had me a bit
concerned that maybe like they're
talking about making squads in classes
rely on each other but then they said
something that kind of watered-down
assault class a little bit cuz valve or
one had that they had the anti-tank gun
rocket gun hit ability right for assault
class yeah yeah there wasn't really an
engineer class but it hardly had enough
rounds to actually stop a tank so you
needed a support guy next to you trying
ammo right um okay it was let's dive
back in yeah okay so this gun is fully
customized you can see it has a leash
camo it has a muzzle brake it probably
has like a custom stock it's got a
bottle opener so this is part of again
they're like yeah I probably deserve a
bottle of it this is all part of their
fluid movement system so that assault
class player he just picked up a third
grenade back that wasn't his grenade oh
I missed that so that was if you want to
go back real quick that was part part of
probably a specialization but that was a
toss back so it comes in that's an damn
cool and we can also see like the large
battle going on in the background um a
lot of this part is showing the prone
system so this is all the moves you can
do while you're prone he's like crawling
spinning his gun is constantly up while
here yeah cool wine that once I made
whatever it's a video game but this guy
is one handing and mg42 crawling getting
kills it's it's awesome I mean this this
trailer alone seems like tonally so much
different like World War one they went
so somber and
KOB with it like especially the I mean
the intro of the game again we haven't
played this but the intro of the game
was you fighting that impossible battle
and everybody dies when you switch
between the characters right this one
seems like they're self-aware I mean we
saw samurai sword we saw this girl what
is that by the way to create a cricket
bat what is with barbed wire I mean I
think you know I think people were fans
of the series right I think I was
hearing some people talk about like oh
they you know people really wanted
another bad company mm maybe this is
kind of tonally yeah holing submission
pulling some of that frankly just like
fun right into the game even then even
then like saying like being self-aware
enough to say he's like or what did she
say she's like I'm not dead or something
what'd she say what she gets shot at the
beginning I forgot what she said she's
like someone says she's hit she's like
no I'm not or whatever and she's
response yeah yeah yeah sure on the
stomach and she's talking and she's got
a claw hand yeah sorry to give credit
where it's due a lot of this came in in
battlefield hardline it was contextual
call-outs crazy melee weapons a lot of
things that I mean like particularly
mean that players know what's going on
without relying on voice chat you know
characters in the game can't actually
call out what's happening at any given
time there was I I mean I guess I didn't
really like constantly like consider it
but that in the background there that
was like dc-10 planes like paratrooper
Harrison I was jumping out yeah so
that's a thing so what they mentioned
for their brand operations mode was that
there are certain maps where you spawn
in the in the plane and you choose when
to jump out onto the map so it's not
just spawn here it's actually
paratroopers okay like how you enter a
battle royale game I mean that we talked
about before like it it can work you
know but like at least at least it's not
from what it looks like it's not just
here's a battle royale mode right like
here is a way of looking at the trends
and incorporate into a battlefield game
and that seems neat in a way instead of
stealing the mode out or instead of
borrowing the mode outright it's like
stealing what makes those games
appealing and what can also work for
battlefield like the survival aspects
being able to drag people being able to
revive
anybody but the medic being more
important in that respect and also
helping other squads it does seem like
there's uh there's more focus on not
dying which sounds obvious but like
again in battlefield one I felt like in
battlefield 4 and hardline I felt like
that sentiment was lost I felt like I
was more worried about kills this one
seems like it's more about surviving so
you can help your squad if what they've
said in this trailer and what you saw
yesterday or any indication ya like the
further on that like that kind of
revived system right like they seem
really heavy handed the idea that like
anyone can be revived by anyone doesn't
have to be just a medic and I could just
do it very fast but then heal and heal
yeah and there was another I think they
mentioned that no longer if like from
battle one which was from a set example
I'm pretty neat but you're no longer
getting warped back out to that
bird's-eye view right like when you
mentioned earlier when you die you are
behind your squad mates yeah it's very
much about keeping that squad alive and
being with your team again you're
spawning in and you're not solo we have
to like opt out manually you're
automatically in a squad that's neat
like I want to see that I mean their
survival aspect also goes back to the
ammo scarcity we saw just before the
woman saved you at the end that you had
19 rounds left the player in the trailer
had 19 rounds left before she nakta
doing the face of the cricket bat and
then again that encourages you to
rebuild those fortifications that
encourages you to actually fight around
those objectives and you know presumably
you said that you heard that yesterday
that you might have already mentioned
this forgive me we're talking about a
lot but the tanks have to return to
objectives to restock that was something
that we hope to be the gotcha okay sorry
so they only talked about that that's
true for soldiers so soldiers will run
out of ammo more quickly and they must
be around either like squad mates orbs
or go-to objectives so everything is
designed to not let you just go roaming
and like you screw off and not pay
attention or I hope the same rings true
for vehicles because then that would say
light that would take away my grab I had
with battlefield one was vehicles
sometimes felt overpowered I mean their
vehicles it makes sense if you had an
anti-tank on it was an easy way to take
them out but I feel like if you had if
they did run out of ammo they to return
to objectives
imagine how like treacherous and scary
that would be to be really far from your
nearest
active run out of your last like your
last shell you're like [ __ ] we have to
get back here for this final push every
has to wait for these vehicles to get
back meanwhile there's people like that
know that you're going back to restock
so they're just trying to take out
vehicles while they're defenseless that
would be really cool again that's just
like pure speculation than like wishful
thinking but I think it would be pretty
awesome like yeah I increase the
reliance on you know like worrying about
your ammo and the objectives which
you're all there already like you know
reinforce it yeah and to reiterate on
the idea of like preserving objectives
is what you just kind of made me realize
is if this does pan out the way I'm
thinking about it is preserving the
front lines in a way right like you're
keeping people coming back to objectives
because I think sometimes like even like
the battlefield one match we're playing
it just becomes kind of like a mix where
it's it's almost like a circle right of
like objectives going down oh great now
they took AI go back to a well now a
loss of D like like maybe that's gonna
keep people coming back to these
objectives so they're not just so
bearing all the time because you spawn
and then you leave right you're you're
now you're falling back so actually if
you go to the end this match in the
trailer you can see that they're losing
a point behind them oh really well I
mean that's just that's just wow hey get
start to get taken Oh F they start to
lose D again in the middle of this yeah
there's more reason to hold on from now
outside of points it seems like it seems
like that's their intent one of the
biggest I love that yeah one of these
criticisms of people I know who play
they play a lot of conquest is that
people just take the points and then
ditch yeah and so this gives you a
reason an investment in the points which
is really important it was like turtling
like an RTS when you're actually I got
see myself being a support player who
takes this point is like you guys go I'm
just gonna hold this for the rest of the
match and have fun doing that I'll build
up anti-tank defenses I'll get an
anti-tank weapon all you know I've got
my cricket bat I'm find my samurai sword
see my super what just happened there
look it on screen if we can show the
execution but it's kind of funny
actually from the player's perspective
what's happening here is the player goes
down and if you go back a little bit
further she's dead and she squads bonds
so this this poor chap Oh ice now you're
I gave you say yeah so she pops out his
butt right there
plus 20 and this dude's in the middle of
it like an amazing execution you might
be that guy and he got squad spawn kill
so she squats bond and then mail aid him
while he was mailing okay somebody else
so they did show actually to be fair
like this might just be this trailer
they showed dangerous ball and lockout
so maybe you couldn't do that in the
actual game maybe they just did that
okay like I don't know it just
immediately reminds me of like Halo
Legends or Halo co-op when you had to
respawn at someone when they were safe I
know there are other games have done
that sense but your honor fire you can't
spot I do yet she was good and she
squats bones yeah listen anything
specific with the trailer I do want to
talk about I'm seeing these characters
in the customization the co-op mode they
mentioned co-op specific combined arms
this seems like a separate mode it's not
war stories it's not co-op campaign per
se it's not multiplayer pvp it's a PvE
co-op mode and you said this might be
their solution to having like a horde
because it is for players and its
randomly generated and also they said
the objective is gonna be different from
time to time it also sounds it almost
sounds like you're dropping into you
know Chow stuns in blood-borne what do
you want to say underground and division
it's like these randomly generated
objectives that you can drop into a
presumably to get aesthetic loot and
just to play with friends against you
know AI enemies it seems very similar to
perhaps onslaught mode from Bad Company
2 earlier which was a PV vironment it's
interesting you actually one of the lead
guys david goldfarb for Belva 3 went off
to make payday 2 which also had these
like co-op PvE like random randomly
generated things but the most important
important part of that is that it is
randomly generated I loved the co-op in
battlefield 3 actually thought it was a
good campaign and it'd be really cool
it's really cool that to jump in with
your buddies and not have the same
experience every time now we didn't we
didn't see it so like I don't know maybe
it's like a map where the Lycian
just move around yeah or maybe it's a
full on they mentioned and store
something about stories so it could be
really cool like if it's randomly
generated stories that'd be amazing okay
if it's just randomly generated I don't
know like crates variety of objectives
like this is a weird deep not deep cut
but a few years ago do you remember
Helldivers numbering this time you
dropped in there was different like take
and hold this weapon placement go clear
out the enemies here go if they could do
if there's a variety of objectives like
so there's not like maybe if they're
rotating through six it'll get old fast
but if you drop into we don't know if
we're gonna go to Russia Norway France
we don't know if we gonna go to Italy
North Africa we don't know if we're
gonna have to take out this artillery
weapon be really cool that'd be fun with
with an evac in the end yeah yeah he
said actually you might have a point
where you have to evac you seem to be
implying that maybe you can lose and
just choose to bail out right like I you
I'm not an ammo right like there really
it seems like picking I mean I want to
say battle royale but just in general
like the survival trend right like
running out of ammo supplies like being
spread so thin like we got to evac now
no let's do this one last you like that
if it's like a breathing world almost in
a way right like I don't know this is
just me spitballing but like knowing
when to call it quits right like we need
to get out of here well it sounds like
an ex comm campaign like different
objectives you're actually trying to
accomplish and you can evac if you think
you're screwed you can just get out
alright but that sounds cool I really do
like the idea of that there they said
more stories as their equivalent or not
was that what was called now filled one
more stories yeah I mean we'll do that
again that was the campaign yeah right
so I'm sorry combined arms co-op but
they are going back to a campaign like
short story form with more stories I
don't know like it would be cool to see
them they're talking about going into
uncharted territory the character they
show close up was a Norwegian woman I'm
you know so it'll talk about Norwegian
resistance against Nazis maybe there
would be like the British commandos it'd
come in and do the the raids on the
coastline
I like that idea I like the idea of it
that's what they try to do with
battlefield 1 explore you know seldom
explored areas although battlefield
it's not usually in videogames but I'd
like to see them go like just show
characters from places that we might not
usually like maybe the eastern early
Eastern Front rather than when Russia's
invading Germany I'd like to see I'd
like to see more in Russia that'd be
really cool because Call of Duty did a
lot of that I mean they did that with
battlefield 1 but again that was world
war 1 I'm curious to see what they do
with war stories I like those
I like the collectively one in like the
Italian one as much in the first one so
I might get my facts wrong in this and
air and you will have to help me out but
the idea with I don't know how much we
touched on it but the idea is that
throughout you know the DLC that's free
that will be coming along are like
different like factions or countries
that are being entered right and with
them come planes and iconic weapons and
stuff like that like that is that is the
case like like well like Americans be
brought in like a little bit later on is
or is that all gonna be a launch do they
have they touched on that they haven't
said what factions are gonna be there we
know and here we saw we had minimum stop
British yeah I think what they talked
what they touched on a bit more with
that seasonal content was like time to
dance it sounds like they're following
like the overwatch Rainbow six siege
model I'm gonna go out on a limb and
assume that like a lot of the cool
customization you get will probably come
from those timed event yeah anniversary
events like holiday stuff
one thing they did this was all
everything we saw today was European
theater concept art included yeah wasn't
any Pacific no Pacific exactly was that
was that like I wonder if they're I mean
they're talking about like trying to
paint the whole war right everybody on
board it'd be weird not to show a whole
you know the part of the war that lasted
longest I don't know I'm curious they're
gonna do that
they talked a lot about Norway so the
one specific example for the story was a
story translated into English was
Northern Lights mmm-hmm northerly was
about a resistance fighters and then she
they showed us like a little teaser
where she drops into the water she's
wearing a pilot outfit and they
basically said that her story is about
family it's not about the larger war
mm-hmm so they said they wanted to focus
on smaller stories they said they went
digging through archives to look for a
little
cool little tails that might tie into
key moments in the war yeah but aren't
necessarily nobody's like storming the
beaches or you know like Battle of the
Bulge I think they said they want to
focus on small personal stories right
and then like we did talk about towing
we talked about vehicles I try to think
what we didn't cover the last thing you
want to show the last thing on that
trailer so there's actually more there
the v1 rocket scene if we can pull that
is v2 v2 I think it's a v2 so the like
they love this prone um it's funny
actually so there's a lot of animations
they showed us they have a test map was
that a glider so that's a that's a v1
rocket Wow
so there's a lot to be right it's a v1
yet okay so this is actually a thing in
the game this is part of the it's called
squad leader radio so it is the
replacement for commander mode well I
don't want in your placement because I
didn't talk about commander mode but
it's the equivalent of commander mode so
going back to the idea of sticking in
your squad your squad has a squad leader
and that squad leader accumulates points
as their squad plays the objectives and
follows orders and basically plays well
the squad leader then can spend those
points in the middle of a match to do
things like call in the v1 rocket Oh
like Pat like more like opieop axe and
stuff yeah okay cool and some of the
things that they were talking about
sounded a lot like behemoths so I I
think the squad leaders can now this is
probably a counter to fortifications the
squad leaders can now call in powerful
attacks as long as people are playing
the squads playing in their squad and
playing objectives to counter things
like giant they can call a giant tanks
and like Oh kinda stuff oh wow ammo
resupplies danny berlin the creative
director during that stream said the
term secret weapons and numerous times
you can turn the tide of war I wonder if
that's in relation to that but I
immediately thought behemoths when you
said that but it makes more sense that
v1 rocket I don't know maybe like like
you said calling a squad of tigers if
you're on the German side or I have no
idea what of what else would be involved
the dogs that gives you more in
senseof to play the objective you're
accumulating points through that as well
because yeah and battlefield one if
you're a commander you were just pretty
much issuing commands right saying let's
go take this objective and if they took
that objective then you get points thank
you my remember correctly you could rake
up experience yeah that was about it in
three you could kill people with
resupply crates which was kind of
satisfying Oh calling it in yeah but
that's all on the ground now so now it's
the squad leaders who have those
powerful attack okay cool I don't know
there any huge points we didn't touch on
they want to talk about there's a lot of
last thing I could think of is
explaining what battlefield ones mode
operations is now called grant
operations about fieldfox yeah yeah
which is like you know a series of
matches and modes that transition over a
period of I think days is what they're
calling it he wants beyond that yes so
one things they talked about was great
operations that went for about five days
four to five days and not real-time
sorry well okay I didn't know if you
meant like it's gonna start on October
19th and you could play at any point
it's it it's like five rounds in game
right okay cool it's different from like
a mixed mode server in that progress
from one carries to the next so they
actually talked about it a bit in the
stream but you know you might have fewer
tickets if you don't do so well in round
two or you might have less ammo they
said you might actually like if you'd
really suck you could actually get to
the last day and have like one mag left
in your gun like Stalingrad yeah so do
ya that example was like if on day four
you have one mag left in your pistol day
five starts with one mag left in your
pistol yeah who's wasting all of your
ammo on like suppressing someone that's
not even there they was [ __ ] I have two
rounds left yeah I mean I think both of
you guys have nailed it and in that they
you know they they they have not talked
about a battle royale which makes me
think it's probably not gonna be in this
game but they have channeled the spirit
of battle rail in a way with a lot of
their mechanics that might appeal to to
battle royale fans
yeah like the idea I'm laughing about
Royale is like I kill an enemy what does
he have right and and and the law that
is looting
like yeah I got a clip left this guy's
got a different gun in ain't what I have
but my odds are better with this so now
I'm a sniping like I'm changing my exact
play style based on you know the
environmental stuff as well like going
to an off school I'm sorry objective
like my continuing my loadout or am I
gonna like ditch it and do something
else yeah it has pretty neat and they'll
be grand operations and like you said
the progress between rounds or days in
the game whether it be four or five is
continuous and then each presumably like
each day would have a different
objective for the attacking team
different things to take different
things to control yeah like I think what
we heard whether or not you heard
something similar was that maybe like
day three would be an airborne drop yeah
as a counter to what events preceded and
Dave puts it three day - right like it's
it seems to be more locked in where it's
not like I feel like with operations
prior where it's you know yes something
happened in the previous map or mode but
the but the slate is kind of wiped clean
it seems like it's the they're still now
a losing side like you're taking
consequences and ramifications of what
happened to the day before and like that
seems neat where you look at a span of
five days and be like there's a there's
more of an interlocking or like a story
involved we're like we were down that we
came back like I'm even thinking of
Carentan like day one would be allies
taking the town day two would be
defending against the German
counter-attack day 3 would be finally
pushing the battalion out of the area or
something w totally or like the idea
that like you made a grand I said a
really last-ditch effort to take a town
successful you do yeah but what happens
in the next and like in the next day
well you're short and supplies are like
you're you know you ran out of ammo now
you have to like defend and hold up and
like pray that you know the next team
isn't gonna like stop your art I don't
know and I'm excited for the mode
because that's what my one thing before
the stream started I was saying I want
battlefield to go back to the big
picture and if you're thinking two days
in advance
that's big picture I like that idea yeah
you're thinking supplies over a whole
campaign not just this firefight I mean
you might get to the end of a round that
you're about to lose in and conserve
your ammo for the next round where I you
it'd be interesting to see people
strategically play switch to your
cricket bat yeah yeah your ninja sword
that you guys saw anything else we want
to touch on yeah um one thing they
talked about was their go back to their
fluid movement system so as a player oh
yeah you're always you're always in
first person and your shooting is not
impacted but what you see from people
around you are people doing things like
slipping and sliding on the mud you'll
see people run up and like throw a
shoulder into a wall when people get
into water they'll like start
high-stepping so there's a lot of stuff
that's invisible to you but will like
help your immersion because you'll see
your buddies doing it I sound tough to
work with like hitbox it's like if you
got if you're running into fhg someone
sees you run into a wall but really on
your screen you didn't I wonder how
they're gonna account for that from the
other person like shooting at you I'm
curious yeah I mean I think it depends
on try to look good yeah um I think
there's a bigger danger this is always
been the battlefield is the perception
of what you think happened versus what
happened yeah like battlefields had some
latency issues where you die and you're
like I was clearly behind that wall yeah
before I died for like a peekers
advantage and siege comes from - yeah um
let me flow through some notes really
quick just to make sure I haven't
because like there's so much to talk
about
yeah you're only on our phone call
yesterday yeah it was actually like a
three hours so they are for half an hour
thing here it's a like three hours
oh they talked a lot about so they
talked about here they talked a lot
about 1942 being there their big
influence all I'm just a start I'm just
gonna hit some random points here they
talked about dynamic weather being in
the game still they talked about amping
up disruption see we're talking about
customization um gun recoil which we
talked about earlier where where where
you shoot is where the bullets go sorry
Rob that was the v1 j v2 rockets if I
was a JB too
that's where you're gonna - okay
specific right you were right I was not
I looked at Vito's baby it just looks
like a giant like Looney Toons a
sprocket it's nothing like I mean it is
really cool how people get through in
like bad company like you get all that
dirt and the concussions that even bomb
you know like mouth would one had that
really cool aesthetic right if it's like
mud and grid and stuff gang on your gun
one moment some dude like blew up in his
face and there was blood all over his mg
that's cool so the commander abilities
where the rocket supply drops
smokescreen barrage heavy weapon battle
pick up and these sounded like the
behemoths the Churchill crocodile which
is the British tank and the squirming
ger stern bagger cool student a dagger
steering that's the German one um sue me
there would be more that's the one thing
you heard about sure okay so that's just
more specifics um I am really curious
about
we did see a number of weapons in the
game but I'm curious how far into
prototypes they will go yeah like that
is one thing at how far because they
were Jets by the end of World War two I
wonder if they're gonna go that far or
if that's part of their like season of
cons I think that's down the road I mean
look at you look at any game even
battlefield 1942 the expansions were
road to Rome and then super weapons of
world war ii which we had freaking
helicopters which i that was not there
but yes the war had the you know like
the German Messerschmitt 262 and the
British like meteor thing there were
jets towards the end so yeah it would
make sense for that to be like a later
update or something like that fly jets
yeah other small mechanics so there's no
more auto spotting they said I think
battlefield one's trying to crack down
on spotting they actually limited the
range in recent DLC so you can't just
like look at a hillside and spam spot
okay and see where everybody is so
there's no auto spotting that's limited
yeah well jumping uh alright dolphin
diving so like you mentioned you might
be able to run and like slide down a
stairway backwards while you're shooting
20 yeah so they said you can jump from
the apex and down so like if you leap
you can't shoot in the first part of
your jump but you can just do the second
part
so maybe dolphin diving will make a
comeback I hope not
oh for people who don't know what
dolphin diving is that's that's that's
jumping and I going prone you could do
that without you oh yeah you can do that
in modern warfare 2 was that like big go
okay you jumping out windows shooting
that make sense I just didn't know that
term apparently dropped shopping but
then getting back drop shotting but
getting back up yes talking about the
matrix yeah just like running and doing
these like dives he's beginning to
believe gotcha
just wait next barrel rolls anyway side
job keep going
can you narrow this hold things aside
yeah really yeah they said they're
trying to get away from revive trains
where like you just kill somebody you
kill the whole squad except for the
medic and then they just all revive each
other but then like a sentence later
they're like oh anybody can anybody so I
don't really know how that fits together
I love that but maybe it's like when
squad hit wiped everybody gets kicked
orbit and that's what they're talking
about yeah but they're trying to avoid
that frustrating moment where you have a
great plan to kill everybody except for
one person you die and then they just
revive everybody there's there's got to
be just like a longer respawn yeah yeah
something like that where you again
you're you're the incentive to revive
someone is very heavy-handed opposed to
like you're like forty feet away from me
I could get back in quicker by
respawning right like I think that's
something they're trying to avoid yeah
just dial back you mentioned like the
dolphin dive but there's also no auto
vaulting right or auto mat mantling so
you have to like I would imagine like
almost double jump or time it correctly
to like jump over a fence or climb up on
a Ledge
trip and faceplant if you don't write
they I mean they didn't I'm not sure
exactly what they were getting out there
I think the issue is that maybe people
getting stuck on things Oh
or like I don't know what they were
saying was it was there trying to make
more fluid movement so you don't have
those awkward moments where you're like
banging on a window trying to read that
then okay um but no you're correct
there's no auto vaulting so you have to
press a button for it to happen got it
so maybe they were worried about you the
fluid movement system where you like
accidentally hit a window and go through
it the drunk effect whoops
wednesday's three-story building hang on
guys I need to do over yeah yeah like in
general that that movement system seems
really cool okay um dang I think that's
it I think time so that's a combination
of what we saw in the trailer with a
southern stream and a ton of what you
heard yesterday if you join us today
thank you so much if you're on GameSpot
or YouTube or twitch we will have more
on the game from what we know so far
Dave Joo in the UK office was at that
event that we just watched on the stream
so we'll have more coming out I'm sure
you'll have much more to talk about
Aaron I don't know maybe we'll do a few
like videos or something when time comes
and then of course III is what three
weeks away or something if that and
we'll all be down there in the Los
Angeles or and up here and say I've just
go covering all the press conferences
and hopefully seeing more battlefield 5
absolutely that I mean we definitely
will but thank you so much for joining
today Robin Aaron thanks for joining
hang on you so much thank you guys for
watching me I'm pretty I'm pretty
excited for it October 19th
is that correct and then so in the
deluxe edition you can play October 16th
and then October 11th if you have EA
access that's the play first trial for
battlefield 5 on Xbox one PC and ps4 all
three platforms on October 11th great
thank you so much for joining and stick
around GameSpot for more from
battlefield 5 we'll see you then
you